Friendster a social network game
launched in March 2003 a bunch of
friends a couple of gaming Knights and
then boom the world never looked the
same again in August 2003 several
employees at e-univers who were also
users of Friendster reorganized the
potential of the social networking
feature with this in mind they decided
to replicate the most powerful aspect of
the platform within 10 days the first
version of Myspace was ready for the
release using cold fusion at its core
technology Instagram Twitter Snapchat
Tick Tock Facebook hike and so on and so
forth the list goes on and on the world
is now brimming with social media apps
games websites out there billions of
dollars billions of users and millions
of hours are spent scrolling like in
commenting engaging and enjoying the
perks of social media Enterprises
however big or small have realized
potential of how these social media
platforms can be utilized to push their
products story or service in front of
potential buyers but how do they keep
track of all their efforts and funnels
and ensure they are up to date with all
the trends in the market and that's
where social media tools comes in they
help consolidate all the processes from
acquisition to budgeting in paid
campaigns to analytics and optimization
and with that being said hello everyone
and welcome to this super amazing video
on best social media tools by simply
learn in this video we will discuss some
of the best tools for social media
managers digital marketers or even
content writers and influencer which
they can use to optimize their channels
and improve performance but before we
begin have a look at simply Run's
postgraduate program in digital
marketing which will help you master
search engine optimization content
marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimize station you are
a management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn tools like SC ranking HootSuite
Google ads Keyword Planner and much more
so hurry up for more details find the
course Link in the description box below
so let's quickly move on to our topic
but before that make sure you have put
your comments in the video in the
comment section below like share and
subscribe to our Channel first up we
have hootsu HootSuite is a famous social
media management platform that allows
users to manage and schedule post across
various social media platforms like
Facebook Twitter Instagram and Linkedin
it provides a centralized dashboard to
compose and schedule post monitor
conversation and mentions engage with
your audience and measure performance
through analytics HootSuite offers
features like team collaboration content
creation and social media listening next
up we have Sprout social Sprout social
is a social media management tool design
for businesses of all sizes it offers
range of features to help manage and
monitor and analyze social media
activity social Sprout allows you to
schedule and publish posts engage with
your audience monitor keywords and
hashtags and measure performance metrics
and generate detailed analytics report
it also includes social listening
capabilities to track brand mentions and
Industry Trends then we have Buzz Sumo
Buzz Sumo is a Content Discovery
research tool that helps you find
trending contents related to specific
topics of your industry it allows you to
search for Relevant keywords topics or
domains and provide insights into the
most shared and engaging content but
Sumo also offers competitor analysis
influencer identification and content
performance tracking making it a
valuable tool for Content creators and
marketers next up we have canva canva is
a popular graphic design tool that
offers a wide range of templates and
feasible editing features making it
accessible to users with limited design
skills it allows you to create visually
appealing social media Graphics
including posts banners infographics and
more canva provides a vast library of
stockheld images fonts icons and Design
Elements to enhance your Creations it
also supports collaborative editing and
offers options for resizing designs for
social media platform after that we have
mentioned mention is a social media
listening and monitoring tool that helps
you track mentions of your brand
competitors and relevant key keywords
across social media platforms blogs
forums and news websites it provides
real-time alerts sentiment analysis and
engagement tracking allowing you to stay
informed and respond effectively to the
conversation about your Brands then we
have smash balloon smash balloon is a
social media plugin specifically
designed for WordPress website it allows
users to display customizable social
media feeds from platforms like Facebook
Instagram Twitter and YouTube directly
on their website the plugin provides
easy setup responsive design and various
display options helping website owners
engage their visitors with Dynamic and
up-to-date social media content after
that we have audience audience is a
social intelligence platform that
provides audience insights segmentation
and social listening capabilities for
businesses and marketers it helps
optimize social media campaigns and
identify influencers allowing for more
personalized and targeted engagement
with the target audience next up we have
social Breakers social workers is a
versatile social media platform that
combines content publishing and
Community Management and advanced
analytics with its social listening and
influencer marketing capabilities
businesses scheme valuable insights to
optimize their social media strategies
with its social listening and influencer
marketing capabilities businesses gain
valuable insights to optimize their
social media strategies by tracking
content performance monitoring
competitors and making that a different
decision social Breakers empowers
Enterprises to enhance their social
media presence and Achieve impactful
results then we have zero Fox Zero Fox
is a leading cyber security company
specializing in social media and Digital
Risk protection their platform helps
organization proactively identify manage
and mitigate risk across various social
media platforms and digital channels
xerofox uses AI driven technology to
detect and remediate threats like brand
impersonation account compromise
phishing attack and malicious content by
safeguarding businesses from social
media related risk zero Fox enables
organization to protect their reputation
customer trust and overall digital
security
finally we have agorables agorapulse is
a social media management and scheduling
tool that offers features like content
scheduling inboxes for message
management team collaboration social
listening and analytics it supports
multiple social media platforms and
provide features specifically tailored
for managing interactions engagement on
platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and Linkedin and that's it for
this video on top 10 social media tools
if you like this video then like share
and subscribe if you have any question
then you can drop them in the comment
box below stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign